in a court in Malaysia 11 suspects are
charged with abducting a Palestinian man
in late September
a local media report said he was
allegedly snatched from outside of the
star residences two building in Kuala
Lumpur beaten and bundled into a waiting
car
a friend he was with escaped and alerted
the police
they eventually Tracked Down the
abductors to a house on the outskirts of
Kuala Lumpur and freed the Palestinian
Malaysia's caretaker home minister says
officials are investigating claims
Mossad was behind the abduction
an interior Ministry spokesman in Gaza
had no doubt the Israelis were involved
we condemn and denounce this new Israeli
crime against our people we thank the
Malaysian authorities and security
services for their great efforts in
throating this kidnapping attempt
according to a local report men believed
to be Israeli intelligence agents
interrogated their captive in a video
call on matters related to Hamas and its
arm doing the qasan brigades he was
reportedly questioned about his
experience in computer application
development and hamas's strength in
developing software the suspects are all
Malaysians a counter-terrorism expert
says it's not unheard of for foreign
intelligence agencies to recruit locals
well I don't think it is only
exclusively the Mozart method of
operation I think it has been done by
the other intelligence Services too we
can see this thing happen across the
world that whenever you're not capable
of operating independently especially if
it is too obvious that if you are
present in certain location and it is
easily being detected then it is
necessary for you to recruit the local
asset and work on your heart
this is not the first time Mossad is
believed to have carried out an
operation in Malaysia
in 2018 a Palestinian electrical
engineer was gunned down by two
assailants on a motorbike as he was
heading to a mosque in the capital his
relatives and Hamas have said they
believe Mossad was behind the killing
the charge Israel had denied
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Kuala Lumpur